furry fun and cuddly these rabbits don't
know how lucky they are to live in
Europe thanks to EU regulations they are
safe from ever being used as guinea pigs
for the cosmetic industry the testing of
animals for beauty products and the sale
of products tested on animals was
completely forbidden in 2013 the
European Parliament is now setting its
sights on a global ban I believe that we
have shown already as the European Union
that a ban can work and this is the time
to actually act we need to make sure
that a global ban is not only EU wide
but also across the globe preventing
animal testing won't be easy four out of
every five countries in the world still
allow the practice and in China where
cosmetics is a major industry testing
remains mandatory though with a growing
number of companies switching to
alternative methods of testing and
consumers increasingly making ethical
purchases the tide may soon turn this
has been a great success where you have
had NGOs where you have scientists and
where you have industries working
together with politicians they reach the
goal the European Parliament wants the
United Nations to make animal welfare a
priority and so does the public
according to a recent year brahma tur
89% of EU citizens also want the EU to
do more to promote the protection of
animals around the world